meanwhile the former president united
states was on another channel yesterday
where he was talking about you know
we've got to fix
immigration and you got to do it through
congress because as former president
barack obama said
what's going on right now
is not good and it's unsustainable here
he is
immigration is tough it always has been
because
on the one hand
i think
we are naturally
a people that wants to help others at
the same time
we're a nation state we have borders the
idea that we can just have open borders
is something that
uh i think
as a practical matter is is
unsustainable
wow how unbelievable is that that he
said something that joe biden won't say
the fact that we have open borders is
unsustainable we are a nation state that
sounds like the average american who we
thought that was a given but not with
this administration well and shinsoki
was asked about barack obama saying it
was unsustainable and
he said open borders is unsustainable
and
gensake said we don't have open borders
so yes he does agree i liked what he
said in the beginning too because i
think all americans do agree with that
we have a heart for these individuals
it's not we we support immigration no
matter where you come from just do it
the right way but it is i mean it's hard
to look at these images of these kids
the little boy it's like etched in my
mind of that little boy with his teddy
bear screaming don't leave me don't
leave me when those coyotes left him on
the border
and yeah it's heartbreaking but you have
to do it the right way because think
even from a financial standpoint how
it's unsustainable how can americans pay
for
all of these people and then now they're
talking about this reconciliation bill
that will send all these illegal
immigrants to school for free someone
has to pay for that yeah they go to
college for free that's fantastic and
they put them in working-class areas
we're going to pay for our kids to go to
school and those kids to go to school
exactly and how dare you complain well
the good news according to the uh
administration is it has zero cost
apparently which is great i went to
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now